[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mandaté tisme des six nations à paris au
stade de colombes il ya là l'italie
l'allemagne la belgique les pays-bas la
suisse et la france
départ du 100 m c'est l'italien beyrouth
il champion olympique du 200 m
quel grand favori il gagne devant le
français de les cours et l'allemand
gamplay michel macquet le capitaine de
l'équipe de france monsieur muscle lance
le javelot à 77 mètre 93 il pas le
recordman du monde l'italien liévore et
essai le quinze 100 m bernard veut
prendre sa revanche sur le belge ben qui
est en tête pour le moment verlaine
s'échappe dans la dernière ligne droite
mais bernard revient et finalement gamme
ce qui ressemble
allah
idriss de mettre 4 échoue de peu
quelques instants plus tard à 2 m eur
[Musique]
enfin le 5000 mètres où le français
baugé rencontre l'amant flos bac
[Musique]
roger est en tête dans le dernier virage
mais flashback leur monde et remporte ce
samedi m finalement l'allemagne remporte
ce tournoi des six nations
[Musique]
magasins fermés mais aussi rideau de fer
arraché c'est alger durant la journée de
la grève des musulmans contre la
partition les vingt-huit mille hommes du
service d'ordre ont empêché que cette
journée soit une journée dramatique
comme ce fut le cas dans certaines
autres localités d'algérie
[Musique]
un instant à rabat le leader du fln
ferhat abbas et l autre du roi du maroc
hassan ii visite au terme de laquelle
les deux hommes affirmé que les
délimitations territoriales entre le
maroc et l'algérie les concerner seul
[Musique]
en tunisie le gouvernement avait choisi
ce moment pour relancer la sphère de
l'évacuation de be there le néo destour
avait mobilisé ses troupes pour
manifester dans la vie
[Musique]
à marseille l'arrivée des hommes de la
11ème division légère d'intervention
retirer d'algérie traduisait sur le plan
militaire la volonté de détente de la
france
[Musique]
paris a si l'on peut dire depuis
longtemps dépassé sa banlieue et les
années qui viennent verront notamment à
l'ouest grossir démesurément la grande
banlieue dès à présent la gare saint
lazare qui draine tout l'ouest de paris
appelle chaque matin à suffire mais que
dire de la station correspondante du
métro par où toute cette foule sm à
travers la capitale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ainsi c'est affirmer la nécessité d'une
grande voie transversale souterraine est
ouest capable de déverser cinquante
mille usagers par heure au coeur même de
paris en résorbant l'engorgement de
salazar ce métro express qui roulera un
jour à 30 mètres souparis doublera le
grand axe routier qui passe par les
champs elysées il aura l'avantagé de
desservir le rond-point de la défense ou
un prodigieux ensemble administratif
s'intégrera un jour prochain au pari de
demain
il faudra attendre dix ans avant que les
maquettes du métro express qu'à admirer
le ministre des travaux publics soit
entrée dans la réalité c'est que le coup
de pioche de monsieur buron qui a ouvert
les travaux de la traversée souterraine
de la scène représente quelques 250
milliards d'anciens francs le prix de la
traversée de paris à 100 km heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
cet été les fruits se trouveront aussi
bien sur la table que sur la tête
c'est ce qu'on pourra constater en
allemagne ou la nana la pêche et les
bananes ont été promus au rang de
diadèmes pour les soirées très habillé
[Musique]
il va toi qu'on ne sera pas en reste
d'originalité à l'heure de la plage les
chapeaux très parisien de rigaud donne
le ton dans ce domaine où la règle
semble être de frapper les imaginations
[Musique]
les coiffures dans ces conditions ne se
refuseront pas une certaine recherche
certaines complications comme dans ses
modèles de carita ou le simple
serre-tête peut faire place ici encore à
une grappe de raisin
[Musique]
de la plage de l'isle-adam aux plages de
l'océan de la manche ou de la
méditerranée un même mot d'ordre donc
dans cet été fantaisie d'abord la
fantaisie il fallait s'y attendre c'est
à saint tropez qu'elle pouvait le mieux
donner toute sa mesure
côté féminin la règle admet cette année
qu'on soit abondamment des tubes pourvu
qu'on laisse apparaître la taille avec
toute la générosité voulu
[Musique]
à
côté masculin on persiste à essayer de
lancer la tenue habillée par excellence
le slip ou le short queue de pie avec
noeud papillon de rigueur
[Musique]
quant aux célébrités du cru on les
retrouve comme sacha distel à l'épi
plage ou le barman installé ses tables
dans l'eau ou bien encore au lieu-dit la
poêle à frire ou les amateurs de
bronzage total passe ainsi des heures à
rocky cétacés dernière occupation que ce
livre par exemple
françoise fabian
[Musique]
avec tout cela on comprendra que
saint-tropez soit le rendez-vous par
excellence des curieux
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
constatons que les mauvaises langues ont
tort il y a aussi des pudeurs farouche à
saint tropez
[Musique]
un van gogh de bronze de trois mètres
veillé par le sculpteur zadkine a
parcouru paris comme pour un triomphe
antique
c'est un triomphe tardif si l'on songe
que chaque tableau de van gogh vote
aujourd'hui des millions et qu'aucun ne
trouve pas d'acheteur de son vivant
[Musique]
au bout de ce voyage la petite église
d'auvers sur oise
l'un les admirateurs du peintre maudit
viennent aujourd'hui à la recherche de
ses derniers souvenirs l'hôtel où il
vécut les derniers temps d'une vie
tourmentée
une minuscule chambre sous les toits une
lampe un cruchon un pauvre lee c'est en
ces lieux toujours hanté par son nombre
d espérer que les amis d'auvers ont
voulu que soit érigée la statue du
hasard team une statue qu aurait sans
doute aimé van gogh
[Musique]
les lieux police des grecs et des
romains la bécade et arabes albecq par
delà le pittoresque d'une femme voilée
ou d'un homme porteur d'eau est au liban
une de ces sites est bénie des dieux où
l'imagination de l'homme contemporain
peut embrasser les siècles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les restes grandiose des temples que
rome a bâti à baalbeck peuvent alimenter
sans fin la méditation intimement mêlés
aujourd'hui au souvenir de la
civilisation arabe
les vestiges de l'oeuvre romaine compte
parmi les plus impressionnants du monde
[Musique]
la porte du monument du temple de
bacchus le plus grandiose qui est
laissée l'antiquité les landes
majestueux des colonnes qui ont résisté
aux tremblements de terre et aux
déprédations des hommes notamment les
six colonnes restée intacte du temple de
jupiter les plus hautes qu'on ait jamais
élevé témoigne de ce que fut l'ambition
de rome faire de baalbeck le premier
sanctuaire d'orient
[Musique]